nobody's buying biden's [ __ ] anymore
no one's buying it here's cnn jake
tappering company realizing that nobody
should be a sitcom nobody likes joe
nearly two-thirds of democratic primary
voters want a different nominee
two-thirds if you break it down by age
94 of democratic primary voters under
the age of 30 94
say they don't want biden that is a
stunning number
yes um
he swept his grandchildren but other
than that i mean like who uh
i mean 94 percent don't want him who
would damn it again 99
democrats under the age of 30. what was
the president's response to a new poll
from the new york times today showing
that 64 of democrats say that they would
prefer a different candidate in 2024.
and um i would also say from that very
same poll um there were 92 percent of
democrats who uh support this president
as well look you know not to be not get
into uh
you know politics from here or get into
any political analysis um you know this
is not something uh you know there's
going to be many polls they're going to
go up but they're going to go down um
this is not the thing that we are solely
focused on
okay so first off let me do the the
second half first that's karine sean
pierre of course you know hershey's the
black lesbian press secretary uh she
completely lied there and by the way do
you know that their new line have you
noticed this we played a clip of gay
pete yesterday
that their new line is i'm not going to
do politics from here i'm at the podium
with the presidential seal behind me i'm
not going to do politics here i'm being
interviewed by someone and i'm the
transportation secretary i'm not going
to do politics here it's so obvious
their game man the curtain has just been
pulled back people but that number that
94
of young democrats don't under 30 don't
want biden to run they do not like joe
biden who is supporting joe biden right
now other than the globalists the elite
the media
who is walking around going joe biden's
doing a heck of a job i feel really good
about the economy i feel good about the
supply chain i feel good about the war
not war half war going on in ukraine
russia i feel good about the way we left
afghanistan and i haven't noticed
anything wrong with joe biden's brain
everything's just fine
no everyone can see it now what's
interesting as tapper and his panel
laugh about that it's like jake you
ushered this [ __ ] in people like to
think that you're the sort of moderate
on cnn meaning you're not completely
insane and a completely totally obvious
democrat operative say like jim acosta
or brian stelter you're supposed to be a
little more of both but you obviously
wanted uh joe biden to be president you
obviously wanted to get rid of trump and
now you're all realizing it and and when
the rats are getting off the ship you
know something's wrong so
we have an opportunity guys we have an
opportunity despite that alien invasion
that i'm predicting despite the zombie
apocalypse and the rest of it we just
got to stay focused know what they're
doing stay calm
and and i think we can get to the other
side of this thing i really do